welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i interviewed aisha
akonbi
aisha has just announced she's writing
her first book called the awokening
which is a great title aisha is a writer
cultural commentator and fashion stylist
she has a really cool social media
presence i'll get into that in the
episode
we talked about cultural issues that are
occurring internationally
how the united states has encouraged
other nations and cultures to re-examine
the way they handle similar situations
like black lives matter we also talked
about the importance of resilience
and being mentally strong when the world
around us can be so turbulent
check out aisha's book coming out in
august
the infos in the show notes and in the
description
this episode is brought to you by merty
creative co i have their beautiful
leather journal
and i'm waiting to grab some of their
other products like folios cup holders
wallets
you can get them engraved for free by
using code mp
and it shows murdy that you came from
here writing is a very therapeutic
experience
i mainly journaled when i was ill and i
actually don't do it as much anymore
although i'm ramping it up
it was helpful for me to get negative
thoughts that were just
spinning around my head out of my head
sometimes if you write them down they'll
actually leave your brain
i journaled for most of my life to work
through what was going on around me
i'm working on a book actually and my
journals like this one from merty
creative
are what i'm grabbing a lot of my
memories from
use codemp for free engraving on their
products
beautiful leather products made in the
usa check out their podcast too if
you're interested in learning how to
start a small business
go to mertycreative.co to find their
products
i hope you enjoy this episode if you do
remember to hit subscribe and leave a
review
if you want to stay connected by
telegram i just got on there
i have channels look up michaela
peterson
on there for a place where i'm going to
be posting articles thoughts pictures
etc
and a group in the channel for people to
talk about god knows what
i noticed after recording the intro that
there was a mess of wires here
but i'm the first to point it out and
i'm keeping the intro
enjoy the episode
[Music]
aisha canby thank you so much for
joining me on my podcast
thank you for having me mikayla i'm
excited
i've i heard of you on instagram because
one of my friends shared
one of your quotes and i was like that
is a smart quote
so i wanted to start off in case there's
anyone
listening who doesn't know who you are
i'm gonna read a couple of your tweets
and i think these are
all in the last two days um
because you have such good quotes so i'm
going to read three of them
if you don't mind no no problem uh i'll
start with
so this is this is one you can accept
people
treat them fairly and extend kindness
without submitting to every tenet of
their worldview
if that's not enough for someone they
are not seeking an ally they need a
parrot
that's a good one many people behave
as if being vocally not racist sexist
and transphobic
makes you morally flawless it doesn't
you can still be insufferable
destructive and ignorant without being
prejudiced
and then the last one having the
acceptable view on social issues doesn't
innately make you a better person
it may only indicate how easily
influenced you are
and those are all in the last two days
so
if you haven't heard of aisha check her
out on social media because she has
really smart things to say and i swear
if anyone was gonna quote me
i would just have wow michaela peterson
so i appreciate your quotes and uh i
really enjoy
following you on social media can can we
start off by
you just giving the audience a bit of a
brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
yes so
um so again my name is aisha akambi and
i'm actually a fashion stylist
i'm writing and expressing myself in
this way is fairly new
i would say i've been somewhat public
with
my stance on things maybe for like the
last three to four years but it isn't
actually anything
that i set out to do so everything is
very new
um so i've been styling maybe for the
last 10 years so i tend to work with a
lot of music artists and
i dress a lot of men in music um and so
this kind of came about just through me
thinking about
how things were changing around me it
seemed very much like it happened
overnight i think everybody has this
sense
it didn't i think there's been a lot of
work behind this but social media came
about
and not too long after that there was
this
great shift in the way that people were
conceiving themselves and other people
and i just found
that really interesting i think i've
just got an amateur
type of uh intrigue about psychology
and philosophy in their mind and why we
do things
and twitter and i guess my social media
presence has just been sort of
looking at that from my perspective and
thinking about how we can
address some of the cultural issues we
have right now with a bit more
sensitivity and thoughtfulness
yeah well that's important right now i
and it has really skyrocketed since
social media i think that's made it a
lot i guess
worse or the divide or the anger people
are feeling is a
very strongly felt over social media for
sure
uh okay so how did you
how did you get started because
if you look at your social media it it
does seem like you're somewhat of
a or you're kind of in a psychology or
philosophy
zone so how did that start it start like
who
what books have you read who have you
been following where are you getting
your ideas or are these just
sprouting from you um well
in 2012 i had a really big shift in my
life where i lost someone really close
to me
and i went through something that is i
guess similar to
maybe what some would describe as maybe
psychosis
others might describe as some form of
awakening
and when i say an awakening i mean in
the sense that i had a really big
transformation in the way that i saw
myself and the way that i understood the
world
um and that was so the incident happened
in 2012 where i lost someone and then
i would say 2013-14 is when it really
started to
i don't know i started to lean into it i
guess they say i started to really
explore
a lot of the collapse that was happening
in my own mind and the things that i was
going through
and then i was led to a lot of spiritual
teachers so i remember
early one of the people that was quite
interesting to me
uh was someone like osho um i found the
way that he
thought about things interesting at the
very least and then there was carl jung
um and who else uh
to be fair lots of people it was more it
was more in the transcendental sort of
um
philosophy and psychology realm it was
it was around that zone and if i'm
honest i think the biggest thing that i
can say that i've done when
because often people ask me who i've
read and i have read a lot but i think
more than that it's about being i don't
know becoming fluent in trying to read
myself
you know trying to read my own
psychology and trying to
you know understand when uh my mind is
trying to present me with the most
flattering view
you know i've i'm quite drawn to the
uncomfortable and
yeah okay well you're very fluent
like everything on twitter it's really
eloquent
um so it's it's it's fun following you
um did you were you always able
a lot of the people who a lot of people
are having trouble right now
speaking what's on their mind without a
lot of fear of repercussion
or you know depending on what they're
talking about
job loss or friend loss or making their
family members angry
so do you have recommendations
i guess uh for people on how to
how to have what might be more sensitive
conversations nowadays
because you seem pretty good at speaking
your mind
and being fairly straightforward but
and maybe i'm wrong but it doesn't seem
to be insulting very many people
i and perhaps i'm wrong so d one do you
have recommendations and
two do you get negative feedback
um you know what's funnily enough
considering i use twitter
fairly frequently no i don't get a lot
of negative feedback and i've
found that fairly interesting um because
i do
see quite clearly how it is difficult to
say
um what you want to these days and i
think the only way that i've been able
to do it so far is
it's about the way that i approach these
topics
and and so you might recognize that i i
don't tend to
be as direct maybe as as as maybe
other people are and and maybe there's
some criticisms
you know anyone could uh legitimate
criticisms anyone could have of that
but i often find when i single out
people like
the liberals or the woke or i don't know
conservatives or anything like that once
you start getting into
uh the political territory in terms of
the language
um people stop listening people just
perceive what they want to perceive of
you and so what i try to do is i try not
to speak in buzzwords
i try not to speak in any terms
uh that are associated with a certain
camp
because often these days a lot of people
are speaking in buzzwords and i think
when we speak in the language of the
time
you know words that are not our own
we're not often i don't think being very
truthful
and so i think it's very important for
people to try and find their own
language
to express these things um i think when
we rely
on i don't know the easy stuff
misogynist or
racist and all of these things you
there's no conversation to be had there
it's just
accusation and so yeah i tried to avoid
that i tried to avoid accusing anyone
and i just tried to observe
okay that's a great answer so uh if i
was to repeat that back to you
potentially that would be criticizing
and maybe i'm wrong but would that be
criticizing more what people
do rather than than naming exactly what
little whatever group they're in
would you say these are the these are
people's actions that maybe aren't great
instead of saying oh it's conservatives
or oh it's liberals
yes exactly for me it's the behavior
more than the political allegiance
that's a good idea and the behavior for
me can
exist in all types of people more than
anything
beyond let's say wokeness or liberalism
i think
what has fascinated me is how
easy um we can overlook uh the negative
side of supposedly good ideas
how we can be sort of self-deceptive
in our own motivations um i think that
was really
a profound realization to me when i
recognized that one stage that maybe
many of the so-called good acts that i
thought i was doing came from actually
other places
um and so that's what i'm really
interested in you know is allowing
people to see that i think we have more
in common than we do
apart and i don't believe that you know
people can take the moral high ground as
easily as they do
and so that's more what my interest is
in rather than
trying to win for my side i don't have a
side you know i don't necessarily
identify politically i'm just
interested in the human condition
cool okay um
well that would make sense about why
you're not getting as much negative
feedback
if you're not going after one group of
people and then you don't have those
people going hey
i'm getting all defensive that's a good
way to do it
yeah and it just seems and even if i did
the thing is although
i may have a political leaning like i
could vote a certain way i think it's
really important for me to not
identify a certain way i think you can
vote a certain way without necessarily
having to identify with such a camp for
me that seems to be
a real problem like a collective
identity crisis
and i'm trying to avoid that
yeah well it's tricky and i think social
media contributes to it a lot because
you end up
following people you agree with and then
you get those ideas just repeated back
to you
and even if you're not necessarily
identifying with a group if that's who
you follow and that's your who you're
around it's difficult i find it
difficult
not to slowly put myself in that and i'm
constantly saying
okay i've been hearing one side of the
story way too often
i need to go search for the other side
of the story just so i know what's going
around
on around me and it's tricky with social
media like i can't imagine
how difficult it is for people who
are really stuck in one kind of tribe
especially people who are younger maybe
late teens or early 20s
must be very difficult to not get
brainwashed by who you're following
yeah which is why i i would always
encourage people to talk to one another
i think it's
it's so easy to misconceive each other
and and assume the worst when we're not
actually having conversations
um and i think it's been hard for me
watching the way the
uh identity issues have played out in
public because you know i've always had
um
close relations with people of all kinds
you know of different races and
religions and things like that so
it's very hard for me to believe
that all x group is this or that you
know and terrible and awful
it just seems like uh we're getting lost
so lost in a self-righteousness that we
can't often see
that we are behaving in the exact same
ways that we accuse other people of
um but anyway i think when we do have um
friendships with people who are
different from us or at least talk to
people who are different from us
i think it's a lot harder to be
susceptible to these types of ideas
yeah it's sad um it's sad what's been
going on especially in the last
couple of years um what's the difference
between
that you see online between some of the
social issues that are definitely
occurring
majorly in the states versus the uk
where you are
um the problem with social media
and i think the issue uh with
english-speaking
countries is that you know america is
such a dominant force in the world
um that a lot of people who are online
tend to take on the same narratives um
so
i would say when it comes to race
although we have a very different
um uh history uh when it comes to race
relations
which isn't to say that racism hasn't
been a part of that but it hasn't
you know the issues that america has are
very different to the ones that we have
here especially around policing
um however you know when
uh the black lives matter protests
happened over the summer
um people would often talk about race in
the exact same way and about the police
in the exact same way
um and so i would say that the um
the problems are different i would say
at least in the uk
people are a lot in london where i live
it's similar to new york but i would say
even less segregated
um because you know people i don't know
if i want to say that people
mix more but people are living together
a lot closer
um and so we're forced to kind of get to
know you know different people and
interact with different people
and so i find it hard to believe or to
conceive rather that
i don't know with all of that we still
can have such uh myopic views of each
other
and so i think we're encouraged a lot by
the american conversation
um i don't think i don't think it's as
heated i don't think race is necessarily
as a heated conversation
um you know i don't necessarily feel
like here in the uk
um people are asking
for similar things i don't think there's
you know there's not necessarily been
as such a strong case around defund the
police or ideas like that
of course you know fringe sections you
know pop up but i don't think it's
something
you know we've taken uh with much
seriousness
uh but yeah i think the danger for me is
that you know america is such an
influence that we
we often sort of download the narratives
happening there without
much critical analysis yeah we've had
the same thing happen in canada
or it was like you can see something
growing in america
and it's like oh how many years it's
like three years it gets here
uh strong enough that you can you know
pick it up around and
i'm in toronto and it's super
multicultural
people live very close together like um
so i was pretty
blind to differences between people
like i went to live in montreal for a
while and when i went there because it's
not as multicultural it was kind of a
shock
because i grew up in a more
multicultural place and so i think when
i've heard about black lives matter
i've it's been much more difficult to
understand because i can't
like you said i haven't really been to a
place where
there's been some sort of segregation or
it hasn't been as multicultural like
there are
there are specific places in the states
that i know might be having more trouble
and i've never been there
so it's hard to imagine um and then i
think
certain areas that do have specifically
race problems too
it ends up spreading around but i mean i
could be wrong about that too i could be
wrong about anything
but as as could i um but it seems yeah
but it seems as though i think with on
the race issue which isn't to take away
from
you know the seriousness of you know
real instances of racism
um but i think it's very easy to want to
see
life through this oppressor oppressed
narrative
you know i think it's easy you know
human beings want
easy ways to think about the world and
easy ways to explain
uh why their lives haven't always gone
uh the way that they should so even if
it's not about race whether it's the
system whether it's our parents you know
or an ex i think there is this impulse
that many people have to sort of
outsource um
their own agency um onto other people
and so i think
with the race narrative i think there's
just
there's the there's already too many
like inbuilt characters that kind of
make
viewing it this way very seductive
because you know you know which side
you're on if you're a good person
and you know what side you're on if
you're if you're a bad person you know
they put you on a certain side of you if
you don't agree with them
um and so i don't know it's just a very
i think it's a very simplistic
uh way of seeing the world which isn't
again i reiterate because you kind of
have to these days which is also very
annoying
it's annoying yeah very and i i really i
quite resent doing it you know and i
probably will stop that soon but
it's just because you know people are so
willing to see you through
um the most negative lens that everybody
tries to protect themselves
um and so you end up saying these really
you know
obvious things like of course racism
exists um
but again i think you do this because we
don't hear each other if we're not
saying if we're not staying on script
then people just
put words in your mouth um and yeah
again i just can't see where i can't see
any positive
or much enough positivity around that
kind of
conversation yeah i think he's touched
on something interesting that it is much
easier it doesn't even matter if you're
talking about race or something else
it's so much easier to blame somebody if
you're not in a good place
like um and it's not fair to group it's
not fair to blame a group of people
generally speaking
um but i certainly did that i had a huge
struggle with autoimmune issues that i
ended up sorting out myself
away from the medical system and then it
was like i hate doctors
and i don't hate every doctor but i have
this built-in bias now
that if you're a doctor you then you
know you're not going to listen like
there's all these
problems i have that i've been trying to
work through because i'm completely
aware of it
but it it's it's much easier for people
to
have something go wrong identify some
somebody and then put them in a group
and then hate that group it is a lot
easier the problem with it
i find is it doesn't actually improve
your situation
like having a whole bunch of hate
towards a group doesn't actually make
anything better and it certainly doesn't
make
your life better if that's what you're
going for
exactly that yeah exactly and it's very
easy to do
but for some reason um
there seems to be a very vocal
minority of people who have a lot of
influence who don't tend to recognize
this behavior in themselves
you know and again this is why i'm very
interested in the idea
of or at least trying to i'm very
interested in
trying to illuminate that we have a lot
more in common in that sense you know
even our bad parts
um often i just think that they play out
differently
and at the moment you know the the hot
button issues are racism sexism and
transphobia
and so that's all that people seem to be
attentive to
but you can be prejudiced in all kinds
of ways and you can still have
discriminatory attitudes
just because you're not discriminating
towards those people
or those groups it doesn't mean that
you're um
above um such instincts um
yeah and that's yeah again what i'm just
trying to
get at a lot of the time yeah
well like you said in that in that tweet
you said
sent out uh it doesn't necessarily make
you a likable person just because you
say
just because you say you're better than
having certain prejudices
yeah no exactly that and it happens on
both political sides or both sides of
any argument
i think that if you're touch the reason
that i say i think and i'm not sure is
because there have been
times of my life where i've been so set
in one direction
and then life just like flattened me
and i found out that everything i
believed in in one area was completely
wrong
uh and i was and then i thought okay
well what else am i wrong about
if i was if i believed that for 15 years
and it was wrong then what else is out
there that i
strongly believe in and don't question
uh so i'm pretty careful with the i
think because i don't want to be
put back in the position where i'm so
sure about one thing that
i kind of pigeon myself into a view
that's wrong and then stop seeing other
views
yeah no completely i i have a similar
sort of hesitation
or a similar instinct to say i think or
in my view i mean even when you look at
my tweets i try not to make uh
you know sort of concrete you know
definitive statements in the sense of
like this is what it is
it's often maybe or could it be or
perhaps
you know i'm not trying to tell people
what to think but maybe just encourage
thinking um and thinking more and
more expansively about things um but
yeah i think that's i think
doubt actually is a really you know
doubt is something i've been thinking
about
for a few months now um and although
obviously self-doubt can have
its negative um impact on us but there
is a
there's a degree of self-doubt that's i
think really useful
intellectually because that means that
we're always sort of
interrogating our own ideas and it
allows us to be a lot more fluid
it's interesting you know we've had
terms like gender fluid and non-binary
become really prominent
and the one place we seem to be um uh
sort of fixed is in our minds it's the
one place that we don't want to be fluid
is in how we look and think about one
another
but yeah i think doubt is um i think dao
is useful and i i think people should um
yeah try to make some use of it
yeah yeah i agree i think if one thing
if there's one thing that people should
do is they should be open to being wrong
about everything they're doing because
everything they're doing could be there
could be something off
there and i definitely just say that
because i had a whole bunch of like i
said i had a whole bunch of things i
really
strongly believed in that i used to
argue for adamantly
with kind of uh i know more than you
type of attitude which is also a bad
attitude to have
um and then i was just wrong completely
so
how did you what made it what made it
easy for you to kind of
acknowledge that you were wrong because
sometimes people can be presented with
evidence and
that does nothing so what would you say
helped you in that regard
oh man well where it started for me was
with this autoimmune disorder
and people people used to come to me and
go well have you tried diet
and which is kind of a condescending
thing to tell someone who's incredibly
ill
because they've probably tried some sort
of diet and what do you mean by diet and
that type of thing
um and i was i was completely on the
medical system side which was there's
nothing you can do
some genetic problem that we don't
understand so i was always like no
there's
pretty much nothing lifestyle wise that
i can do
and i argued that and fully believed it
because that that is what i learned
growing up and that's what i was told
and then it you know i did some sort of
diet test and it had such profound
effects on my health that it flattened
me i was like this is i've been dealing
with this for like
17 years i've had joints replaced
because of it and i could have been
controlling it
so it wasn't really a choice exactly
that i made
i don't think i was like kind of forced
into it with
just life circumstances the evidence was
so overwhelming
right i went from having physical
symptoms to being in remission for the
first time ever
um and you can't argue with that really
so it wasn't much of a choice i made it
was just like
life whacking me on the head until i
paid more attention
yeah what happened yeah yeah um what are
your plans for the future
are you going to continue this you said
you're into style right you're styling
musicians
yeah so i've been a stylist for about 10
years yeah so i started that when i was
uh you know
fairly young i was around 20 i believe
when i became a stylist
and of course i was young and the idea
of dressing your favorite musicians and
getting to travel the world with them
uh was very oh yeah
yeah and as much as you know styling
will always have a place because i
i really like self-expression and
helping people feel confident through
their style or helping people find their
style
but i guess as i've got older and my
priorities and
values and principles maybe have changed
um i do think that i will be doing more
of whatever it seems like i'm doing
right now
um so you know i've often been doing a
lot of public speaking
and i'm writing um hopefully working on
a project and maybe at some point i
won't say too much about it yet but
maybe there could be a book maybe not i
am not saying um but yeah i'm working
towards you know
um a big project where a lot of the
things i've been talking about on
twitter and been putting on social media
i can you know go into them in more
depth and
and talk about where my perspective is
coming from um because i think
one thing that's very easy if there is
any criticism i get
um and whenever i do get this it's quite
gentle and it hasn't happened very much
i think people often believe that my
stance comes from privilege
you know that's that word again that we
hear so often these days
um and so many people believe that in
order to
take on a certain um philosophy that i
have
or a personal philosophy it must come
from you know
having financial stability or something
like that
um and i don't think that's true i think
um
because essentially my you know one of
my fundamental principles is about
resilience and curiosity and i think
that's
available to us all um and so
yeah i'd probably do more work in
in yeah sharing ideas you know i think
it's about time
that we i don't know think about
even intelligence in a different way i
think there's a lot of academic
intelligence but not necessarily enough
emotional intelligence and i think
emotional intelligence is something
that's um
uh really important um
and yeah so in whatever way i will be
encouraging that and and just thinking
always
thinking and just trying to put what i
think
there isn't enough of in the world well
i'm for that
i don't know much about about your
styling background because i've been
like i said i've been
following you on social media for these
like really
i find insightful little i'd like ideas
you put out there so i definitely think
that's worth pursuing because they're
good you're very eloquent
you say many more words than wow it's
good it's good
uh so back to the idea of so part of the
problem you were talking about privilege
that
that might be one of the critiques you
get
um part of the problem nowadays is
people are attacked unless they're in
in certain groups right like you're lot
allowed to talk about
being disabled if you're disabled um
what whatever female problems if you're
female black problems if you're black or
whatever group it is which is
a huge issue because people shouldn't be
judged based on
where they're in they should be judged
on
what they're thinking or how they can
think um and
i've i've talked about this quite a bit
on the podcast but you mentioned
resilience
and i think part of the problem with
blaming groups of people for your issues
um it's kind of uh depending on what the
issue is it's kind of an avoidance
strategy rather than working through the
problem
like um we're being taught at the moment
to avoid
stressful conversations about things you
might not like or about things you don't
agree with
and everyone's so up in arms every time
they hear any conversation where people
are and it irritates me if i'm listening
to a couple people talk and i
completely disagree with everything
they're saying it's annoying to listen
to
um and i think i'm fairly open-minded
and it still bugs me so i get why people
avoid it but
even in psychology the way you get
through
issues is by exposure
right exposure therapy which is kind of
being dampened down now with
avoid ideas that harm you or just erase
them don't even have conversations don't
let people have conversations if you
don't agree with them
um which definitely leads to problems
people having secret conversations it's
not like they go away
right um the type of people having
having these
negative ideas ah so
for the future what do you think people
can do
to try and avoid the direction that i
think we're heading in like in my
opinion
this divide and the anger people are
feeling is probably
going to get worse yeah
what do you think i often think you know
i don't
share the view necessarily that we live
in
an oppressive you know innately
discriminatory
um hellhole essentially
you know like i don't believe that you
know
and so but even still many people do
believe that
and i recognize that and so if that's
the case
then it's doubly important to be
resilient
because if you're gonna take on or
survive in this oppressive
patriarchal sexist white supremacist you
know
hellscape um then you really need to be
resilient you really need to kind of
have
some relationship to stoicism you really
need to
be someone who is mentally strong i
really believe that um because
if that's the world that you think that
you're living in well then there's a lot
of people around you who
who are probably going to be people that
you don't like and how
how do you live with them because you
have to you can't kill them you can't
just you know you can't get rid of them
you have to exist around these people
so i often see uh the stance that i've
taken as the only sort of like
it's just pragmatic to me you know i
think it's
uh it's not about privilege it's about
being pragmatic we have to exist with
these people
anyway um and so i would say
uh you know when it comes to these ideas
that we're taking on and these
new things that are popping up that are
quite trendy we should always be asking
ourselves you know
have has what i learned have what we
should often ask ourselves
is what i'm learning here and the
information i'm taking
is it making me a more wise person am i
more curious
am i more interested in other people um
do i have a
do i feel a great capacity for love um
yeah and if it's not doing anything
positive many other words too
um or not enough positive you know if
it's told you maybe
who to dislike who the who the the
baddies are
and all of these kinds of things then i
would really weigh it up but i really
weigh
up if if what you're digesting is
healthy um but also recognizing that you
know
discomfort won't kill you you know it
really won't i it's so weird that we've
got to this place where simple
disagreement i find it mind-blowing
you know every single day i genuinely
can't believe that you know
adults you know young people because
it'd be different if it was just young
people you understand that it would
you know if it was just students but
it's academics
you know a lot of this comes from
academia
um which is why i mentioned earlier i'm
interested in
pushing a different form of intelligence
if you like or maybe it's not even
intelligence but like it's just about
being emotionally mature
and there seems to be a lack of
emotional maturity
um so yeah i would just say um
you know sorry i think i might have
digressed a little bit no that was good
that was good i think i think the
general rule
um if what you're listening to
isn't i guess encouraging love
if it's encouraging hate then maybe you
should be careful about what you're
listening to
and and i think what happens too is
people try and go for the side that's
encouraging love and then they get over
there
on that side and then slowly it switches
right
you get you get you switch over to the
side that you think is the good side and
then you're like oh well
the other side is evil the other side is
this and if you're hearing those things
regardless of
whatever group you're in or whatever
side you're on then you should be very
careful about what you're listening to
i think so yeah i'd leave it at that i
won't i won't ad lib yeah
that touches on victim a little bit
and about resilience i thank you the
point you made
too that if you are living in a world
that is a hell hole
and some people are for sure um i would
agree that the majority of people
especially in
well the places that i'm familiar with
it's pretty good compared to
some other places in the world but there
are people who whose lives are are
hellish
and specifically for those people they
need to be resilient in order to survive
if they're around toxic people or try or
who are out to get them
like they need to be strong and
resilient and they need to be able to
face
their fears and uncomfortable topics or
they're not going to make it right
yeah that was good i think yeah life is
just going to be
a lot worse for you so if you truly
cared about
so-called vulnerable groups or
marginalized groups you know as we often
call these people i mean
i say so-called just because i don't
like to conceptualize and think of
people
primarily by their their misfortune but
if we
care for these communities in the ways
that we say we do
and we know that um the odds are against
them
as many people believe um then it's
doubly important to
arm that those communities um
with the sort of mental tools um that
can make this
life feel doable that cannot make you
that cannot sort of compound this
feeling of oppression that you have
um you know life isn't a rehearsal as
far as i understand you know and we have
uh a short it's both a short and a long
one
um and so it's both too short and too
long i think to
feel those ways and um and i just think
that a lot of
influential people a lot of people who
should know better i think
will have a lot to answer for you know
and i think people get
so caught up in trying to be right um
and trying to look like the most
empathetic person that they actually
really neglect
the people that they say that they're
fighting for and
and the people that they claim to be
speaking for they're not speaking to
those people anymore they're only
speaking and trying to
um win against their opponents over the
last
year i've been i've been watching
because i've been pretty
involved in i guess specifically the
politically correct
thing that's been going on um because of
what my dad got
you know weirdly famous for in 2016.
um he he was going on about oh there's
this politically correct agenda and it's
in the humanities and
i was kind of like okay dad calm down a
little bit like it's in the humanities
but like it's not gonna get
out of hand um and then in the last year
i think it's definitely gotten out of
hand um
do you i don't know if you agree with
that but regardless
the last year the stress that
everybody's been under right
like even someone who doesn't have any
other issues in their life
has been stressed this year because of
things being shutting
shut down and covet and maybe the fear
of getting covet or their relatives
getting covet or whatever
um it's possible i guess that
instead of things continuing on this
kind of scary downward slope
of anger that's been happening it's
possible that when things kind of calm
down
in the world maybe people will lighten
up
i've been trying to figure out you know
if we're headed in
if it's if we're doomed or if we're
going to recover
but what are your thoughts are we
heading in a good direction or do you
think this is just like covid
stress anxiety existential dread like
what's going on right now
i'm i'm really not sure it's a good
question and every time i get around
people who have some investment in these
types of conversations i
ask the exact same thing i always want
to know where
people think we're heading if they think
this is something that will be overcome
in a short while or if this is
potentially a new norm and
already i can see that you know while i
do think
the general public have a lot of fear
around
uh the cultural issues talking about
race or gender or something like that
i do think there has been an increase
in um some public figures uh
speaking out against the type of culture
that we've been existing in this sort of
suffocating um
slandering i don't know just very
hostile environment that we've
had to kind of go through over the last
few years
and so because more people i think are
feeling comfortable to do that
i think that is going to hopefully have
some
influence um even in race you know i saw
you speak to coleman hughes the other
day
um you know who someone i very much
admire um
and i see they you know there are a few
more people
i think you know race is a very hard one
i i believe especially for
a lot of young black people to
to sort of think
in alternative ways should i say i think
it's very hard to
step away from the mainstream
narrative but i'm seeing a little bit of
an increase there
and i think that's positive um because
even if those people are wrong
what's positive is that they can air
what they have to
express you know without fear or without
being branded as bigots and hateful
people
and the impact that has on their own uh
mental health and
you know confidence and all of these
things i think has been really
detrimental it's been bullying
essentially
and so i see that i see more people
pushing back um where we're gonna go you
know because sometimes i've often
thought about this as a trend you know
i've thought about it as
like um you know yeah a new sort of
trendy
ideology in the sense that you know we
are now having to live our lives in
public in front of people and we've
never had to do that before
so ordinary people who never signed up
to be
public people have all become we're all
part of the public now you know and
anyone can criticize us so long as we
have a social media account
um and so i do understand that because
of that there is this
extra want to be perceived as a good
person
you know and i think living our lives in
public
is something that we haven't maybe
psychologically
thought about what that means yet you
know what what what does that mean to
live in public and to have people view
you
and to criticize you and how does that
change the way that we behave
i i think that has had a profound effect
on us
um and so i think that's what we've been
that's been a part of the tension as
well
is is figuring out how to live with each
other
figuring out how to live knowing our
each other's thoughts
um i don't know i don't sorry again like
i i digress a little but
do i think we're heading somewhere
better you know
you would have thought the pandemic
would have been the thing you know as we
face
this global situation together
you know and and regardless of your
privilege
or lack of you know we are all um
anyone is prone to potentially becoming
sick from something like this
um and that hasn't it hasn't it doesn't
seem to have moved us
you know we've politicized it and we've
become tribal about it
um and so i'm not so sure
but i think as i think it has it is
becoming
slightly more embarrassing to behave in
a certain way
i think it might be and i think that's
good i think it's becoming somewhat
embarrassing to kind of
um perceive every idea that you disagree
with as you know hateful i think it's
becoming childish you know
to i think people are getting that out
there that it's a childish way to
perceive the world
um so i hope that has some influence
yeah okay i kind of agree with you and i
didn't know if that's because
of the news sources that i'm more
attracted to or not
but i do think that some of the
particularly the buzzwords that were
used a couple of years ago
might be attracting a bit of
uh skepticism from its readers like if
you read an article and they say
you know they use a whole bunch of these
buzzwords that were
that have been popular for the last four
or so years um
prejudice or oppression or kind of those
things i think people are kind of aware
oh that might be a biased article
that might be happening more uh my hope
is
that a lot of what's going on right now
and i think it is i think a lot of
what's going
on right now is because people are so
stressed
um like um you're in the uk so it's
in london it's pretty shut down from
what i know um
oh what's it like there it's crazy
i mean uh i think in europe uh we've
our government has been you know maybe
the least competent
in in addressing this and so we're in
lockdowns we're not in lockdowns and now
there's sort of tears as to which place
is going to be locked down in the
country
and what places aren't a lot of the the
messaging is is mixed
um no one really quite knows what to do
a lot of the information is
contradictory logic has gone out of the
window
um so people are very stressed um
so yeah i do think that's a big part of
it but actually
touching maybe on something you
mentioned earlier with you know your
your father becoming um very popular as
a
as a result of what happened in 2016
with political correctness
um but one thing that i think you know
he's done a great job of identifying is
this um
this purposelessness that people feel a
lack of purpose
you know which i think has been um has
contributed to
uh why he has been so popular also
because for one it's a it's a positive
message
and not many people are out there right
now um
trying to encourage people to find
purpose within their own lives
you know it's very external you know
everything is kind of like
stand for something out there you know
like be a part of this
movement do this out there these people
um and so i think the lack of
purpose we have felt for whatever reason
in in recent years has definitely also
um contributed to um the cultural
yeah the culture was if you like yeah i
i completely agree
i i used to be so irritated i always
hated school
like i didn't like elementary school i
didn't like middle school i didn't like
high school
i vaguely tolerated university like i i
didn't like any of it i thought it was a
waste of time and
one of the things that they should just
be teaching across the board
is have some goals like what do you
envision
or what do you want your future to look
like and then
backtrack to figure out the steps you
need to make in order to get there
and then make a plan for those steps and
implement it and that would be
the proper way to give people goals that
they're actually interested in
rather than whatever they're doing in
school right now which is
i don't know wasting time torturing
students to death with boredom
i don't know what your experience with
school is but that was mine learning how
to spell for
seven years yeah so i'd say i blame that
lack of purpose
on just a terrible education system
and i guess i mean it's up to the
parents too if you have kids
then you should be trying to help them
goal set and
figure out what you want their future to
look like and what they want their
future to look like more importantly and
we certainly aren't doing that so it's
no wonder people are getting caught up
in
purpose like here's a here's a purpose
and i seem to be on the right side of
things and now i have something to fight
for
um yeah i i completely agree
you uh you mentioned
earlier i don't think i touched on this
you mentioned
characterizing people by their
misfortune which is
something that you should avoid which is
what you said um
and i also completely agree with that i
think
one of the problems with identifying
with some of these
groups is they lump you in by what they
perceive as your misfortune which first
of all
isn't necessarily like um how i dealt
with
having an autoimmune disorder the only
way to deal with having something
terrible in your life is in my opinion
again is to try and figure out what the
positives are
and you generally speaking even if
you're in a really terrible situation
you can figure out the silver lining if
you
really try and so for autoimmune
disorder it was like well
now that i'm aware of my health i'm much
more aware of my health than other
people my age
i may have put off a lot of problems in
the future by being forced into figuring
it out early
so that that's really positive and then
because i'm aware of it i can be aware
of it for my daughter
right so and those are just a couple of
the positives because i figured it out i
can help other people who are
experiencing similar problems and maybe
what i did will work for them
and so that's how i've managed to turn
around the misfortune of having like a
seriously debilitating disorder that i'm
now thankful
thank god i'm free of but part of the
problem with characterizing people by
their misfortune is
you trap them in whatever you think is
their problem and you say oh well you're
you're kind of screwed
you've got these walls around you and
it's society's fault
and there's not really anything you can
do about it which is incredibly rude
it's like putting
in somebody in an invisible jail yeah i
agree
yeah i agree i'm it's uh it's the part
of everything that's happened that
probably is most hurtful to me so it's
not even just about angering or annoying
or irritating i think it's hurtful
um because you know many people um
because the their life circumstances
haven't been ideal
are waiting for a narrative a belief
system to come along
and and and tell them that they can't do
any better
because these feelings are you know
negative feelings can be just as
addictive
as you know things that make us feel
good um maybe even more so
uh i might argue otherwise we'd probably
all be in the practice of good habits um
so when people are already prone to you
know a negativity bias
um and these learned people who and i
don't necessarily think they're doing it
intentionally i think this is what
happens when people have a profound lack
of self-awareness
and and and and in intellect and
academia doesn't give you that it
doesn't give yourself awareness that's
for sure
um and these are these things this is
where we you know where we relate on the
education thing i was terrible in school
i i didn't
i didn't uh i wasn't considered bright
you know i definitely would never have
been predicted to be doing anything
that i'm doing right now um and i
believed i internalized that i wasn't a
bright person either or not capable um
and it's only through going through a
really harrowing experience you know
with losing a sibling which is
how a lot of my perspective was
developed
that's terrible right and which is a
situation
that you know and especially because you
know my my brother was
um he was murdered so it wasn't like you
know he was ill or anything like that
and so that could very much be a
situation
where you could turn cold very easily or
you can hate the world
and you can blame everything and i did a
bit of that
for a while um but it wasn't productive
you know it wasn't helpful and it wasn't
it wasn't even true it was from that
tragic situation
with my brother um where often
one wouldn't think you can see a silver
lining for many people there is no sort
of sil not silver lining but there is no
positives in a situation
like that but as you say like you can
you can if you're looking for them you
can find things that you can you can
learn from every situation
and you know i i learned from that
situation and i i recognized at that
point that
you know um if anything
you know death can also exist to teach
us how to live
you know it's a reminder constantly you
know that
um time is precious you know and what
you do with your time is precious and
and that's something i really deeply
internalized from that situation
um so again i i may have gone around the
houses a little bit but it's
very deeply um hurtful when i see
people um encouraging
people who may be in precarious
situations to feel this way
um when the other perspective is just as
available and is far more productive
yeah that's quite a story and um
it's definitely the case that there are
situations that are
you can find positives in situations
that
are all almost all negative right
it's kind of i mean jesus i haven't gone
through something like that so i can't
even comment on that
but i mean from my perspective the
autoimmune
disorder for instance uh it's still
difficult to turn around right
so people in really [ __ ] situations
even if it's completely unfair like you
don't want to go to someone and say oh
you're
you know your mother has cancer look on
the bright side
because like there isn't a bright side
but in order to survive through things
that are that
horrible sometimes you need to
make one up or figure it out just to be
able to make it past
that uh one of the things i think we'll
wrap
up with this one one of the things i've
touched on in previous podcasts is why
horrible
circumstances just soul-crushing
circumstances can breed
i find they breed two types of people
they either breed someone who's
broken and resentful and mean and
horrible
which is kind of fair if you go back and
say well look what happened to them
but then it also breeds this person
who's more compassionate
and kinder
and i've been trying to figure out why
it breeds two separate identities from
people who have both experienced things
that are unfair
and mean clearly clearly you've managed
to recover from
well recover somewhat anyway from what
you went through
so what are your thoughts on that what
are your thoughts on or or
rather than thoughts how do you think
people who are in
terrible circumstances can come out of
the other side
um a more compassionate kinder person
rather than being resentful and angry
and like
slowly having that waste them away
um how do i think people can come out
um well i i think the negative states
that we go through in life and the
inevitable
um horrible things that we'll all have
to face eventually like losing
um people that we care about um
losses at work and you know
relationships ending
um i think that we
we recognize that everybody is going to
have to go through those things
and everybody is impacted by them and
and slightly altered in some way forever
and we're all dealing with that and and
i think for me
being in that position um
with my situation um and allowing it to
really let it break me i think that's
what it did you know when you you
your initial question about you know why
does it breed these two different
personalities and it's something i can
continually think about and you know i
probably
spend my life thinking about and trying
to work out if it's possible to
induce the um the more positive
you know experience like can we induce
that can we make
that happen without without that
horrible experience
forcing the person into it that would be
ideal right
and i'm i'm trying to work it out like
how do we make that
happen um and i think it's
i don't know i mean again i think
it sounds weird to say but i often think
that when we're in these dark
spaces we have to kind of let them
really break us like not
not kill us i'm not talking i'm not
advocating you know trying to be
suicidal or anything like that but i
think
you know for me you know and maybe this
is my
sort of thought on spirituality uh which
is
a way that i i would say that maybe that
i
i have a spiritual take on the things
more than i would say that i have like a
political take on things
i may not use the typical language of
like spirituality because i think
that stuff on the internet as you know
is very um
you know that's the whole it's brushed
off it gets brushed off too
it gets brushed off and and also it's
not even just that it gets brushed off
there's a lot of
there's a lot of just kind of
performativity even around
that subject and and just like what i
would think about religion i think it's
a very personal relationship so i don't
think
i have to present my information
directly in that way
but i would say that it comes from those
types of insights
and and for me i would say beyond
the thrills and trills of the word
spirituality
i think it's about allowing yourself
to break so thoroughly that you have
almost no choice but to love other
people
you know it's a it's uh like everyone in
fact i think it's
it's not a choice you know there's a
place that you can get to i think
in these very negative situations where
it feels as though someone else has
taken over
you know and i yeah it feels like
someone else is taking over
and i don't know i just really do
believe that there is this space within
all human beings i think we all have it
um
that is boundless in its ability to be
positive kind uh empathetic and
and and full of depth um and i think the
way that we live our lives
um because of the entertainment um just
the many distractions that we have and
the many
arguments and the many sort of
trivialities we get caught up on
um distract us from this um but i don't
know i think there's um
again that was a very messy way of
trying to answer it that was beautiful
i thought that was beautiful it's kind
of you
but yeah i think we should just
recognize that you know we all
we're in this together it's a joint
project however you split it it's a
joint project and um
we're all gonna have to face the the
hardest parts of this
and no one escapes that i think that's a
good place to end things
aisha where where can people find you
and so i am on twitter and instagram
and uh you can find me at my name which
is aisha underscore canby that's
a-y-i-s-h-a-t underscore a-k-a-n-b-i
i realize makayla will probably have
that somewhere on the screen
so yeah you can you can find me there
yeah okay well thank you very much for
coming on that was that was lovely
thank you for having me
you